[Music]
gromson
another white game all right let's go
let's go again
alright the french so
those of you who've been around for a
while you know what we're doing against
the french we're playing the steinitz
variation
e5 so this is the advance but instead of
c3 we play this very odd looking move
knight f3 which has brought us a lot of
success that's far queen b6 our queen b6
is what we usually face and
so this is surprising to me because i
would imagine that most people would
take on d4 here but this doesn't change
how we handle this position we still
play bishop d3
we don't care about c takes d4 knight c6
okay so i looked at this line a little
bit
and i concluded that rather than
castling here
it's a good idea to take on c5 in this
position which leads to a very important
pawn structure well it basically leads
to exactly the same bond structure
that would have occurred if black had
taken on d4 except we don't sacrifice
the pawn
and this position is already pretty bad
for black
so
how should we develop
our pieces here
normally
normally
the best scheme of development is knight
b to d2 and the knight b3 i'm sure you
guys are familiar with this maneuver
this is very typical in such positions
but
given that black is not very well
developed in this particular instance
you can also consider developing the
knight to c3 which may seem a little
awkward but it threatens knight a4 which
would eliminate black's very important
dark squared bishop
why is it important because black's
other bishop is terrible you should also
be aware that the greek gif sacrifice is
on the cards in case black castles king
side so knight c3 is the sort of
principled move here the most testing
move
and that's what we're going to play
another maneuver that you should be
aware of especially given queen c7
happened
where else can the knight go
so first of all knight a4 is excellent
in this position the bishop doesn't have
a lot of good squares we could play
knight a4
we could also play knight b5 and try to
sink our teeth into d6
let's see what happens if we do that
now are we gonna go knight d6 check
immediately well probably not that would
be upon sacrifice how can we prepare
knight d6 who can well now of course 96
is very strong
but notice that we can prepare knight d6
by getting our bishop out to f4 here we
don't need to do that because d6 is
uncovered
so let's go 96 check while it's not too
late
okay and with such a monster pawn on d6
black's position already sucks
now to play these positions well
there's a couple of things that we
should understand the first is
we are not terribly afraid you shouldn't
be terribly afraid of losing this pawn
worse comes to worse you lose that pawn
you can continue playing you've got a
lot of other trump cards in this
position
now i'm looking at a move here that
can be a little bit hard to explain it's
just sort of a move that improves our
position
and it's not really a waiting move per
se it's just that we're kind of waiting
for black to
reveal how they want to
uh develop whether black wants to castle
or keep the king in the center and the
sort of standard move that does that is
rookie one right that's kind of the move
you default to
in many of these instances it also kind
of
provokes black into castley because it
creates an x-ray against the e6 pawn
which in turn those of you with a sharp
tactical i might see bishop takes g6
and queen takes d5 is sort of a small
threat which would win a pawn knight
before
okay that's very good
now we don't want to give away d6 right
i said it would be okay if we do but
that's not the ideal scenario how do we
go about defending the d6 pawn can we
defend that pawn at all
well you would want to play bishop f4
but that blunders the bishop so don't
abandon that idea can we get bishop f4
anyway
yeah we can take the knight first
we can eliminate the knight and then we
can put the bishop on f4 and
because black doesn't have a dark
squared bishop
that pawn on d6 is going to be a huge
problem for black because black will not
be able to attack it with anything
i mean look at how much that disturbs
the coordination of black's pieces
another thing to realize is that by
castling short black is opening himself
up
to potential attacks down the h file
with for example rook lift
yeah with the added benefit of ruining
the pawn structure and opening up the
hval now you might say well wait a
minute what if black doesn't castle
doesn't the h file benefit him not
really because other than the rook on
the h8 black doesn't have any other
firepower on the king's side so castles
okay
now i propose that we don't
procrastinate
um the thing about these positions is
that the longer you you wait and you
sort of accumulate
the greater the chance that your
opponent has time to consolidate so
we've got a couple of ways that we can
that we can attack here many many good
options here
um a classy positional move
with a tactical basis would be c2 c4
and hoping for takes d7 trapping the
bishop but let's go for black's king
well queen d3 blunders the queen
yeah knight g5 is the move i want to go
i want to play because
as i'll explain after the game black is
a very
annoying idea in this position
uh the idea of going f6 f7 and f6 and e6
e5 and if black gets both of those moves
in that is the one way in which we we
can
our grip on the position can be loosened
because the bishop's contact with the
pawn will be lost and i think everybody
can see that that's an unpleasant
scenario so knight g5 has several ideas
the main one is preventing f6 because e6
is gonna hang so it's also prophylactic
in addition
to being an attacking move obviously
okay bishop d7
now
we can definitely go
queen g4 that's one option
but the funny thing is that queen g4
still allows f6
i don't like queen g4 because of f6
instead i would prefer a slightly
different maneuver
i would prefer a slightly different
maneuver
how else can we get the queen to the h
file
in eduardo your move is good too c3
would chase the knight away to c6
well queen f3 is what i had in mind
black has a very nasty response to queen
f3 believe it or not
that i'm trying to figure out
i'll talk about it afterwards
there is our opponent will probably not
see it but there's something a little
bit annoying against queen f3
you could also play h4h5 that's true
you could also lift the rook up to e3
let's go rookie 3. let's do the rope
lift
let's do a real close
we'll check afterward i feel like there
must be something very convincing here
i'm not seeing anything
that
inspires too much confidence but this i
think should do the trick rook c8
okay now
i think the time has come for us
to get this queen into the attack with
queen g4 now that we have the additional
idea
of
a um of a
going queen h for b going rook h3 i
think it's time to
press the button here so to speak
it's not so simple these positions are
never as easy to win as they seem and it
can be infuriating
now let's see if our opponent finds a
defense against queen h4 there's only in
my opinion yep he does
okay but now i take c6 that's the whole
point
and i think i calculated a very cool
line here let's hope it happens
i'm really hoping for knight takes c2
that's part of what i was calculating
i'm really hoping for knight takes c2
which looks really bad right it looks
like it forks
looks like it gives a gives a fork
might take c2
now
now the point is
play queen takes g6
okay well what's happening here and
probably rook h3 was probably just
better wasn't it no no no no no this is
fine so
what's happening here is that we're
threatening checkmate
with running checkmate on g7 so taking
either of the rooks is out of the
question
now looking at this for a little longer
you might say well wait a minute black
can play bishop takes c6
and after rook takes c6 then black can
take the rook in the corner rook take
knight takes a1 and there's no longer
checkmate on g7 but what is the key move
in that position
after bishop e6 rookie six knight a1
we have rook e6 to e7
okay well that's a little anticlimactic
with the unstoppable threat of checkmate
i think that wins for white
yeah i don't know what it is with like
mape threats and maybe somebody can fill
me in like i guess that's just what
happens when we put a lot of pressure
you know these kind of blunders are
common
yeah i did not play in the cleanest way
i have to admit
so
you can look at
at some point i'm gonna group all the
speedrun games by opening and we've had
a lot of these lines a lot of these
french games
so dc castles knight c3 is very strong
here
uh preparing knight a4 and also knight
b5 knight d6
so generally
as i said knight bd2 and knight b3
is the is the traditional um is the
traditional square development square
for the knife
yeah but it was already lost no knight
c3
queen c7 knight b5 back to b6 we give a
check on d6 this is all amazing knight
g6 rookie one
uh sort of a semi waiting move knight
before we take it and go bishop f4
castles
and i wonder if we chose the wrong
approach or maybe there is something
cleaner
knight g5
bishop d7 rookie 3
rook c8 queen g4
yeah so why why was i afraid of queen g4
straight away
because of f6 and after 96 rookie 8
the point behind already having a rook
on e3 is that now we can double on the e
file and protect the e69 here the knight
on e6 is really really loose
and if we play queen takes g6
then black takes on e6 and guys come on
you know full well oh but no white is
winning here
oh and i miscalculated white this
actually was the best i think white is
winning here with what move
i think a lot of you think oh you know
this 1700 missed maiden one what an
idiot
but obviously he's just been under a lot
of pressure bishop h6 unstoppable made
on g7 the pawn on d6 is covering both
squares on the seventh rank
that was a complete mental lapse by me
and this is exactly the same thing so
the best move here would have definitely
been queen g4 straight away
okay so i didn't see that
instead i decided to prepare that with
rookie three
why didn't i play queen f3
so who can tell me what defensive idea
does black have in this position and i
think i already mentioned it
but this is why i almost played queen f3
aiming for queen h3 and mate
the problem is black was e5 yeah
what is the point of that move well the
point is that
black establishes contact with the h3
score which means queen h3 is impossible
and if you take
if you take with a rook you get forked
if you take with a bishop you also get
forked and i thought this is really
really unclear probably white is fine
uh because of the attack but i didn't
see anything convincing here
so
this is a classic develop uh classic
defensive idea you push a pawn out of
the way in order to protect the square
with your bishop
um and so i decided to make a sort of
not even a not a waiting move just an
attacking move to see how black
is going to continue and after rook c8
only now did we play queen g4 and my
point
was that after rook fba by the way queen
takes g6 is still winning
my intention was to play rook ae1 in
order to protect the knight
and after knight takes c2 i calculated
queen takes g6
and if well there's a mate threat and
efficient p6 then after rookie six we're
attacking the rook on e8 it's a classic
scenario right if black takes the rope
then the other rook takes and there's no
longer a rook on e1
is e4 the right follow-up afterwards for
black where
you mean after e5 yeah but i'm assuming
we'll take the pawn so there will be no
e pawn
if you drop the bishop back to g3 then
already black can take on c2 with a fork
because we don't have any attack down
the h file
so
yeah so this um was not a very smooth
attack how would i have defended his
black here
um you know what i would have done here
i would have gone rook 8 e8 that's
probably what i would have done
intending f6
and if queen g4
then after f6 knight takes e6 i would
already play knight take c2
and the opportunity train has passed
oh but now i think there's knight takes
f8
now i think there's the berlin move
knight takes f8
and bishop g4 there's rook takes c8 and
white is two rooks for the no but this
is unclear king f7
this is a complete mess
so i would have played rook a8 so that
queen takes g6 would not be possible
anymore because black
is making contact with the knight two
different ways
so this is already very very messy
um
does that make sense the idea behind
rook a to e8 to prepare f6
yeah these are hard positions to
to make heads or tails of now white
isn't under no obligation of like queen
g4 my idea with white was actually to
swing the rook to b3 and try to pick off
this knife
using the pin
um
i'm sure the computer
would have lasted me
how would the h4h5 idea work do i
struggle with executing such pawn storm
attacks successfully well
the idea behind h4 is very simple you
want to play h5 you want black to take
and then you want to get your queen to
h5 and then you want to checkmate on h7
the problem with h4 is that it's very
very slow
h4h5 takes two moves and two moves in
such a position is kind of an eternity
and after h5 i was concerned about f6
but it occurs to me now that white i
think has a very powerful and brilliant
mating idea who can tell me
what um
i think this idea leads to checkmate
what concept does white have here
h takes g6a you just sack all of your
miners
queen h5
and the hero is the pawn on d6
that is the real hero of the position
not the queen and the pawn because
otherwise the king would easily escape
through e7 to d8 people forget about
that constantly they think this is made
but it's never actually made if the king
can escape
toward the center here the d6 pawn is
holding that square
so it may be that h4 was also very
strong
and perhaps black doesn't have the time
to organize a successful defense to that
now the thing is after rookie 8 h5 black
and ignore black does not have to take
and black does not have to play f6
for example black can play knight c6 and
prepare e5 that way
and this also seems a little bit iffy
for white although hgfg
and now queen g4 looks incredibly strong
as well let's check the computer let's
see uh
let's let's have the computer laugh at
us a little bit
okay so
knight c3 is correct as i i actually
analyzed this i remember that
knight b5
knight d6 checkers so we played
correctly here
rookie one is the top mode very good
push for g6 bishop f4
bishop f4 is not oh we could have played
a3 and i mentioned this idea we could
have just gone for the pawn
a3 and queen takes d5 yeah that would
have been very very strong but okay we
played bishop f4
knight g5 is good 57
now we played let's see let's check
queen g4
g4 f6 now f6 is good for black oh
there's g5
yeah there's this intermediate move g5
which leads to a total mess
that is a move that i missed
yeah g5 here
so it's good that we didn't play queen
g4 i played here
that's actually not a bad move
after rook c8 queen g4
yeah black had to play f6
black had to play f6 here oh no he did
he did play f6 this was the decisive
mistake knight takes c2 he had to find
an only move g5
queen f5
gf rook h3 is mating
so black has to find rook feat only move
man
look at this line rookie one
gf queen g6
no but again you can see that even the
computer struggles to defend this
takes takes takes takes we're
threatening rookie seven so knight c6
now d7 threatening rookie eight so black
has to go rook f8
and what a position white is down a
piece
but
white hasn't completely tied down we go
h5h6
so black has to force matters with
knight e5
takes takes queen e8
and now black has to give up the knight
or the pawn
which leads to a better queen end game
for white
simple line right there very simple line
wow
i'm sure this is where we would want a
higher def computer
but the engine is giving still an
advantage for white here which is pretty
out pretty awesome
so i didn't play too badly
um
i didn't play too badly it looks like i
never relinquished the advantage but
i kind of rushed it with bishop f4 this
is a great lesson in never rushing a
move right bishop f4 is super automatic
you're defending d6 but if you take a
little bit longer you say wait a second
i can actually win a pawn with a3
and queen takes d5 and now white is
completely winning
but okay if you guys want we can look we
can look at um
if you guys are interested i can load
this into chess space and then we can
really uh
dig deep and see what the actual
evaluation is
okay so we see here
knight e5 is the top move at a high
depth knight e5 wow knight g5 is the
second move okay so we played knight g5
that's good
bishop d7
and now the key position
so a3
on depth 30 is the top move
let's see
a3
knight c6 and queen d3 well that makes
sense actually because you want to go to
h3
this actually does make sense
um
and now if black plays e5
then we play bishop takes e5
and obviously f6 is fails now to queen
takes g6 look at this position no matter
which minor piece you take the other
minor piece participates in the
checkmate that's awesome
and if black plays knight takes e5 and
then f6
then we have queen takes d5 check and
knight f7 check and you save all of your
pieces with a winning position
so because rook f7 queen f7 and you're
hitting the bishop simultaneously
right
so that was the best move according to
the engine rookie 3 arm move
is not great
let's see why it's not great rook ac8 so
rook ac it is the top move along with
knight c6
okay queen g4 is the top move as well
f6 yeah no the line that the chess.com
stock fish game seems to be the one that
this stock fish is giving as well
f6 96 and now the only move was g5
so we were looking at queen f5
wow queen cease oh my god what a lion
queen c6
well look at this craziness rook takes
c2 is the second best move bishop g5
queen d6 bishop h6
rook f7 only moved queen g6 sacking the
knight and then going rookie one
oh my god rook c c7 rookie 6 rook ce7
threatening the back rank mate queen
takes f7 check
the point is you're distracting the rook
so that you can take the queen
and if the king takes then you take e7
black has to give the queen away
and then you fizzle out into this very
very simple end game which of course is
equal
ridiculous line
and that is if flak had gone
that is a black at the end rook takes c2
but apparently according to the engine
queen c6 just totally inhuman what does
this move even do queen b6 to c6 just
calmly repositioning the queen
no clue what the point of this move is
oh my god look at this idea rook c3
no way rook c3 black's
only move is rook c8
sacking the queen
and the point is that after bishop takes
c6 white's queen is trapped the only
square is g6 and the bishop keeps
pursuing the queen
between e6 and cheese this is a
ridiculous idea
i mean even for like uh i've nev this is
you don't see this often what the hell
only move rook ce8 in this position
rook c3 rook ce8
i'm gonna take a photo of this i'm this
is a great position for my like highest
highest rated students absolutely wild
so it is a draw but
this is wrong this is what the chess.com
engine oh no this is we knew this was
wrong
we were looking at this line
and then we were also looking at rook
feat
which is what the chess.com engine game
and as you can see this is wrong
although it's not
totally winning it's it's this is the
line that we were looking at
which ends in a better queen end game
for white
yeah but it all stems from g5 it's clear
that g5 is the only move you cannot
afford
to give up the g6 pawn once that pawn
falls
it's just checkmate i mean it's plus
eight
takes takes this was correctly
calculated by me
and what's incredibly important is the
role of this bishop on f4 it's covering
the c1 square
i hope you guys saw that otherwise this
would be losing because rook c1 would
force white to waste a move
but now you just go rookie seven
and rook c1 you can just take it with a
bishop
so
unconventional thank you for the 26
months
well
but in this position 95 is also very
strong and the point of 95 is to prevent
f6
right you're just preventing f6 in a
different way than knight g5 it's like a
symmetrical idea on the other side of
the the board right
and if queen d6 you have this i think e5
and just knight takes c5 and you're just
winning here
so
knight e5 is more accurate here but
a3 and queen takes d5 i should have seen
i rushed bishop f4 you can't rush any
move right you can't take anything for
granted
and a3 would have eliminated all of this
intrigue
but everything else was correct like
this whole knight b5 idea was correct
bishop e3 apparently was very strong
look at this move bishop e3 seemingly
walking into a fork
but in reality you have knight b5 and
knight b takes d4
and the point is that at the end of this
line black can't take because of the
typical idea but should be five check
and the secondary point is that if black
takes on e3 you have an inter mezzo
knight b5 now
by eliminating the bishop you're able to
get your knight into d6 and black cannot
capture it and you open up the f file
this looks totally devastating i mean
the pressure on f7 is going to be
unbearable
so it's kind of cool to analyze with an
engine you get to you get to you expose
yourself to all of these cool ideas
and some of them are going to stick like
some of them
you might find yourself applying in your
games but don't feel badly
if you know if you miss the 99 of it of
it because nobody sees
most of these ideas
all right um enough though enough we're
gonna pause here
thank you everybody for the support
always appreciated thank you for hanging
out i'll see you guys later
goodbye
[Music]
you